shocking body camera video shows a Man
attack multiple police officers working
to restrain him all while making
outlandish claims including that he is
God show me show me that I'm your father
and that your first rule in the Ten
Commandments is on your father God rule
number one
the bizarre incident happened near
Oklahoma City on January 13th 9-1-1
dispatch received a call from a person
who heard yelling and gunshots officers
arrived to 54 year old William Seeger's
home to find the front door glass quote
completely shattered they later found a
shotgun with quote damage to the stock
body cam shows officers coming face to
face with Seeger who was sitting on the
hood of a vehicle put your hands up
put your hands up
put your hands up when Seeker refuses to
stop officers tase him but even after
that he continues to resist he's then
tased a second time
[Applause]
here
this is the help for those tickets right
here but that proves to be only the
beginning of the altercation show them
talk to them reassure them reassure them
we assert them about God
Randy I'm God
I'm God
prepare yourself 30 minutes
30 minutes
Lainey Wilson will arrive
in the flesh
thank you Jesus
I had to go through all this and let me
down I'll bring the leaves me down
Release Me
I am your father
all right sit up what's up I'm your
father no one else we're good
I'm your father
I'm ready
I'm totally ready you guys can stop the
ACT
go ahead and step back and show them
that you're acting as Seeger speaks with
officers he continues to refer to
himself as God he even says they're all
acting you care about my well-being
right now help me back up and show him
that I'm okay
because I'm lost
Seeger then seems to believe one of the
officers is a congressman eventually
saying quote the movie starts right now
let me up and I'll tell you right to
your face I'll stand with you give you a
hug this is the man I admire most
excuse me what's your name brother
oh what's your name I'm God God
help me please Hagins Congressman
Higgins what's wrong with you today
I want the world for you to present this
wall you escort me you smoke your tires
let me get in your vehicle that you
designed for me
and then show me I'm there
please now this is it the movie starts
right now the tribulation
the movie if you got your popcorn this
is it Tammy if you want me
I desire you
can you get an fi on the person though
let me uh car for me Higgins
Higgins will you let me up hit me up
like show them who you are
you are
let me up right now
unhook me right now just like you I was
God I am God Seeger continues with this
theme asking for the show to begin
obviously tell the world who you are
bring your vehicle down the road
there you go
will you go show everybody who you are
introduce yourself sure go down this
road a few times everybody move out of
his way
pulling anyone's driveway let's start
the show right now later even as he
continues to refer to himself as God
Sierra calls an officer Jesus yeah how
can we help you
Jesus I'm Not Jesus yes you are now I am
God
I'm talking to you
please help me out of this let me up
Jesus just take me to my house let me
get ready and knock on my door tell talk
to the people until I get ready give me
an hour and a half
the person that's supposed to bring me
my outfit Chris LeDoux he's alive again
this is the country artist I want the
world to listen to every pure word he
says
why did I have to go through this this
is where we are mankind
why are we going through this what's
your please
what's your name what's your name again
I forget I'm sorry I'm gone no we're
asking when I came to when I came down
and you saw me come down and come back
to earth yeah I am he continues to refer
to the officer as Jesus and eventually
lashes out saying McDonald's is the
reason for his quote disease
Jesus tell them step on the street and
push that thing back put it where you
want it and let's start our journey and
come right back and take these off me
real quick they hurt
seriously I'm God and they hurt please
Jesus Jesus Jesus
try to feel you motherfucker you can eat
hamburgers from McDonald's that's where
I'm getting all my disease McDonald's
hey brother calm down all right we don't
want to hurt you okay I'm ready please
help me out the way you want to get the
crap out of you show me show me that I'm
your father and that your first rule in
the Ten Commandments is on your father
God rule number one
body camera video shows officers
continue to try to calm Seger
God damn it someone get this out of my
eyes now I've got here's this animal the
quicker you calm down the quicker we can
get out of your face okay Seeger then
says he will stop fighting back but
immediately resists officers
take me to the hospital I will not fight
anymore I'm God
it's then that Seeger's dog rushes over
he screams at police calling the dog his
son
real fabric 68. hey calm down and we can
help you okay real Maverick 68.
that's who I am everything I've ever
said as man is true Maverick
is this your dog I'm fucked up yes bring
him here this is my dog he's here with
you the under speaker
show yourself what kind of dog is it
he's a he's a mix but he follows
Authority his father of authority just
like him I'm God his father was mine I
am God and that's my son let me have to
protect him this is dog's really sweet
yeah she probably has most I'm worried
about my dog more than anything in the
world I'd rather see you in the face
right now Point Blank for the 12 gauge
another 10 gauge next
I have water all over my pool it's got
holy water drink from that
the Third Temple has already been made
after
after eager compares the situation to
quote what Jesus went through this is
pain guys
this is what Jesus went through show
them Jesus see a kind and you never want
a man to go through this ever again stop
this right now and show them no more
acting body camera video then shows
Seeger bite one of the responding
officers
I'm God that hurts don't do this to God
or am I kick you in the ball I'm gonna
hit you in the balls right now let me
show the world who are you I can't see
you in my eyes right here
hey stop biting me
please I'm tired I feel with your pain I
feel your pain stop Jesus please I've
heard him okay okay okay okay okay good
you picked me again I will so fucking
pick you up hey calm down well he's
already kicked me once watch this people
it started right now they're not kick me
in the ball do not stop once officers
successfully strap Seger onto a
stretcher he's taken to the hospital
Seeger is later taken to the Canadian
County jail he admits to officers he's
confused about what day it is
it's still Thursday right or is it
Friday
I'm not sure
what day it is in the last couple days I
wasn't sure if today's Friday or if
yesterday was I didn't sleep much last
night Seeger tells an officer he is
finally calm you calmed down quite a bit
so that'll probably help
10.0 to 0.0 according to an incident
report from the Oklahoma City Police
Department Seeger could face multiple
charges but so far the District
Attorney's office has not filed any
charges reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie